the former president Donald Trump is
freaking out over possible criminal
charges coming his way and speaking of
Liz Cheney he's calling out Liz Cheney
as being despicable Trump completely
lost it on his uh social media platform
I guess we call it truth social truth
Central yeah Trump freaks out over
possible criminal charges by blasting
warmongering and despicable human being
Liz Cheney I still do not believe that
Donald Trump is going to be charged it's
just an opinion and it's an empirical
question at some point he will either be
charged or he won't and I don't know
eventually he'll die and at that point
we would say well he's not going to be
charged he's just it's over he's not
going to be charged we will know the
answer at some point
in the interim my opinion is Trump is
not going to be charged at least not
likely for anything related to the
January 6 committee although if charges
are coming I think they're more likely
to come from Georgia and his attempts
there to a strong arm his way into
getting George's electoral votes I need
so Donald Trump over the Fourth of July
weekend took to his a truth social
platform with a completely unhinged
message saying quote and I will try to
do this in the best most accurate way
possible quote warmongering and
despicable human being Liz Cheney who is
hated by the great people of Wyoming
down 35. keep saying over and over again
that her fake unselect committee May
recommend criminal charges against the
president of the United States who got
more votes than any sitting president in
history
although millions of votes fewer than
Joe Biden he doesn't mention that even
the Dems didn't know what she was
talking about why doesn't she press
charges instead against those that
cheated on the election there's no
evidence anyone did or those that didn't
properly protect the capital he went on
to say why doesn't the highly partisan
unselect Committee of political capital
T thugs the same people all Trump haters
and profiteers books speeches Etc that
were involved with impeachment hoax
number one impeachment hoax number two
the no collusion Mueller report and
overall the all caps now greatest Witch
Hunt in the history of the USA go after
the people who have been rioting burning
down cities what city burned down
leading the massive crime wave and
killing many all over the U.S including
drug and human traffickers no let's get
Trump anyone Donald Trump killed Donald
Trump Trump's worried Trump's unhinged
Trump's out of control that being said
I really don't think he has much to
worry about in terms of criminal charges
now he also completely misunderstands
how the January 6 committee Works he
talks about well why don't they go and
press charges against someone else the
January 6 committee doesn't press any
charges the January 6 committee
investigates with the investigative
power that house committees have if in
their investigation they uncover
potential or evidence uh evidence of
criminality they can make a referral to
the justice department to attorney
general Merritt Garland and they may do
so now to Trump's benefit if you have to
say well why is it looking not so bad
for Trump there is no evidence
whatsoever that attorney general Merritt
Garland has any interest in indicting a
former president there's just no reason
to think that he is willing to do that
the January 6 committee has exposed so
much and the justice department has said
well we're paying attention to the
proceedings oh okay well what do you
plan to do
are you even willing to do what the
evidence suggests you should do if
indeed that is what surfaces well
they're not commenting on that much like
I said earlier in the show I'm seeing no
evidence that Joe Biden is actually
going to run for reelection I'm seeing
no evidence that the Merrick Garland
justice department is truly willing to
prosecute a former sitting president and
so we may see something out of Georgia
the fact that Trump is going so nuts
should be interpreted not as a sign that
he's likely to be indicted but is a sign
that he has done things worthy of an
indictment that's the guilty conscience
that I see from Trump but I don't
actually think he has anything to worry
about let me know what you think we'll
have all the clips and Trump's truth
social truth sensual posts on the David
Pacman Show Instagram which you can find
at davidpackman show as many of you know
I'm a busy person I don't always have
the exact correct nutritional plan for
my meals every single day and that's why
I also take a multivitamin and a couple
of supplements but doing them all
separately can be a little bit time
consuming which is why athletic greens
is just fantastic and they're one of our
sponsors I've been using the athletic
greens since last year it just really
simplifies nutrition I just do a scoop
of the ag1 and I'm getting 75 high
quality vitamins and minerals and my
probiotics and it's all from whole food
sources I drink it in the morning I know
I'm good I don't have to be messing
around with different pills and
supplements or whatever or spend time
planning it when what time of day do I
need to take each one I just get it all
with one scoop you can put it in a
smoothie you can drink it straight it
tastes great and then I'm just good for
the day it supports gut health and I'm
getting every everything that I need and
I'm looking for athletic greens is
giving my audience a free one-year
supply of vitamin D plus five free
travel packs when you go to
athleticgreens.com Pacman and the link
is down below